-Our next guest will be touring
Australia this September
with his new show, "Epic."
Making his
American television debut,
please welcome the very funny
Simon Taylor.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hello! This is fun.
The last fun thing I did before
I came to America was,
I played "Monopoly"
with my parents.
But they play "Monopoly"
by the modern rules.
Do you know
the modern rules of "Monopoly"?
That's when my parents
start with all the property,
and I just wait for them to die.
Because they're Boomers.
They're so condescending.
They're like,
"Well, if you want to get into
the housing market,
Millennials,
maybe you should stop eating all
that avocado on toast."
How dare you?
Let's do the math
for the Boomers, okay?
25 bucks a pop for
smashed avocado, eggs, coffee.
You do that four times a month,
that's 100 bucks a month.
That's 1,200 bucks a year.
So if I want to put a deposit on
a house in an inner-city suburb,
I have to stop eating
avocado toast for
20 to 30...
thousand years.
There's no way into
the market for my generation.
They don't cater auctions
to Millennials.
There's no auctioneer going,
"Alright, ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the auction just for
the under 35s here today,
just for the Millennials here in
the beautiful suburb of
outer, outer Manhattan...
Kansas.
We're in Kansas.
Should have just said that.
We are starting the bidding
on this beautiful
2"x5" studio apartment.
For the under 35s, starting the
bidding today at a job.
Who's got a job?
Does anyone under 35 got a job?
Can I see a job?
I need a full-time job,
not working part time
in a café, sir.
I can see the tattoos.
I'm looking for savings now.
Does anyone got savings?
Anyone under 35 got savings?
No.
Spent it all fixing your
broken phone screen last year.
I'm looking for
rich parents now.
Can I see rich parents?
Going once. Going twice.
Going three times.
Sold to the foreign investor."
It's the best we can hope for.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You clap, but I'm sad.
I live with
my wonderful partner, Lucy.
And living together puts
the relationship to the test.
For example,
Lucy was in bed one night,
eating cookies
because she'd given up.
And...
[ Laughter ]
...she had crumbs
all down her front.
And she's like,
"Babe, I can't move.
I don't want to get
crumbs in the bed."
So I vacuumed my girlfriend.
And now we're married,
so it all worked out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't deserve that.
She proposed to me,
which was pretty cool.
Any ladies here
propose to the men?
Give us a "yeah."
That's emasculating. Okay.
It was amazing, right?
She got down in the
middle of the street, right?
Everyone was walking by, and she
said "Simon, will you marry me?"
And everyone walking by stopped,
they started
applauding and cheering,
which made it so hard to say no.
And my instinct was like,
"No, no, no,
I was going to get around to it.
I'm transferring money
between accounts.
Give me time."
But as I saw the tears of joy
welling in her eyes,
I realized in that instant
just how much
money I was going to save.
And I said "Yes," right?
Weddings are expensive, man.
Millennials now are
sponsoring their weddings
and putting it on social media
just to make
some money back, right?
Which I think is so tacky,
and I wish I'd done it.
I would have had
a commercial break
during the ceremony
if I could have.
Like, "I, Simon, take you, Lucy,
to be my lawful wedded wife.
But now,
a quick word from our sponsor.
Going through a divorce
can be tough.
That's why Gibson and Power
Divorce Lawyers
are here to help.
Use the promo code
'Till death do us part.'"
Another awkward thing that
happened between Lucy and I was,
one night, we're at the laptop,
and I said,
"Hey, I'm going to
order some food for delivery."
And in front of Lucy, I opened
what's called an incognito tab.
Some people know what
I'm talking about.
Some people are lost.
For those who don't know,
an incognito tab
is a tab you can open
in your browser
that doesn't save what
you search to your history.
So you could look up
anything you want, sir,
and your partner wouldn't know.
You're welcome.
Some people knew what it was,
so they giggled.
Some people didn't know what
an incognito tab was,
so they were quiet.
But some people knew what it was
but stayed quiet
because they were thinking,
"Don't give
away my secret, man.
That's my special time."
So, in front of Lucy,
I've opened an incognito tab,
accidentally,
just, like, out of habit,
because I do it so much.
You know what
I'm talking about, dude.
And she said, "Why did you open
an incognito tab for food?"
And I'm like, "Uh...
I just don't want people knowing
what food I get delivered."
She's like, "What food do you
get delivered?"
And I panicked and said,
"Interracial.
Fusion. I meant fusion."
My name is Simon Taylor.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Fusion. Fusion.
Simon Taylor!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Simon Taylor.
He'll be touring Australia
this September.
We'll be right back, everybody.
Come on back.